foreign
[Music]
also on New Year's Eve we have of course
again compiled the most relevant news
for you we talk about the hottest rumors
from the MCU the upcoming filming of
alien Romulus and the current status of
Margot Robbie and the Pirates of the
Caribbean spin-off we also reveal when
the first trailer for Fast X will be
released How likely a new Terminator
movie from James Cameron is and why
Wolverine and Deadpool can't stand each
other have fun watching
there was news about the production of
the upcoming Fast and Furious 10. AKA
fast X in an Instagram post Vin Diesel
is joined by fellow actress Jordana
Brewster who plays Dom toretto's sister
Mia in the movie in the caption diesel
hints at a trailer in less than two
months that would fit in nicely with the
Super Bowl which will take place this
year on February 12th when many major
Studios traditionally promote their
films and series via trailers or other
Clips other news concerns the possible
return of Gal Gadot as Giselle the
character actually ended up dying in the
sixth part but that doesn't mean much in
the Fast and Furious universe as her
lover Han also reappeared in the Night
Part since Gal Gadot definitely has a
free slot in her calendar after her exit
from Wonder Woman the rumor is probably
not totally made up of thin air we are
definitely looking forward to the
potential Super Bowl trailer fastx will
hit theaters on May 19 2023
Avatar the way of water the second part
of James Cameron's passion project is
currently being screened in cinemas only
recently the box office takings hit the
1 billion US dollar Mark however there
are other movie series that the 68 year
old popularized above all Terminator
starring Arnold Schwarzenegger The Cult
film series still enjoys great
popularity nearly 40 years after the
original movie and after a number of
flops is in desperate need of a major
makeover in order to appeal to fans once
again on the smartless podcast hosted by
the three actors Jason Bateman Sean
Hayes and Will Arnett Cameron was a
special guest shortly before Christmas
and shared his plans for a new
Terminator movie under his Direction
according to him it is not yet decided
whether he will make another Terminator
film but if he does he would put a
special focus on the artificial
intelligence of the robots and not just
portray them as evil machines the big
question is whether a Terminator film by
Cameron would even be feasible his
priority is undoubtedly Avatar as he has
emphasized often enough so assuming that
five movies are actually released the
Terminator flick would come out no
earlier than 2030 which is a tad too far
in the future even for the world of film
all the more so since Cameron would be
76 by then nevertheless anything is
possible in Hollywood and you can look
forward to further news from Cameron as
long as you have the necessary patience
the rumor mill is bubbling especially
with regard to the two future Marvel
movies Captain America New World Order
and Thunderbolts the main talk is of a
Celestial named Tiamat who was turned to
stone by Cersei at the end of eternals
so far the huge Rocky figure rising from
the middle of the Indian Ocean has
caused some confusion among fans as it
wasn't clear to what extent it would be
relevant to the story well the answer
could be that there is a source of
adamantium on genocia island or Tiamat
Island at least that's what the current
speculations suggest since this is even
more valuable than the vibranium found
in wakanda there is of course a lot of
demand for it leading the way is the new
American president Thaddeus Ross who
will be embodied by Indiana Jones star
Harrison Ford following the passing a
previous actor William Hurt according to
the latest rumors president Ross will
play a decisive role in both Captain
America New World Order and Thunderbolts
both of which will be released within a
few months and will attempt to gain
control of genocia by any mean is
necessary as a ruthless antagonist
according to the current rumors the
villain the Sentry whose real name is
Robert Reynolds will also be introduced
into the MCU he too has been given the
infamous super soldier serum which Steve
Rogers also received but in contrast to
him he has become a lot stronger and is
even considered one of the most powerful
MCU characters of all in addition to the
obvious rumors about the two movies in
question there Remains the possibility
of introducing the X-Men into the MCU
particularly for a new Wolverine despite
all the rumors we should not count on an
official statement for Marvel in the
coming months which means that
discussion among fans will prevail for
the time being with the release of
Captain America New World Order on May
3rd 2024 and Thunderbolts on July 26
2024 at the latest we will find out
which of these rumors turn out to be
true in the end
what Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
revealed in late summer that Wolverine
and Wade Wilson would appear together in
the upcoming Deadpool 3. the excitement
was correspondingly high among fans in
the past few days Jackman has been eager
to talk about a few details about the
film on the Empire film podcast he
disclosed that Reynolds and Jackman's
film characters will find each other
pretty obnoxious on a scale of 0 to 10
it ought to be a clear zero after all
both are the exact opposite of each
other he also reveals to Sirius XM how
exactly they plan to bring his character
back after his on-screen death in 2017's
Logan thanks to multiverses and Cable's
time travel module stolen from Wade
Wilson in Deadpool 2. there are several
options this will not ruin the
storylines of the Wolverine films and
especially Logan which is very important
to him in the wake of the interviews
rumors also surfaced that TVA agent
Mobius and Mobius will make an
appearance in Deadpool 3 as well in
order to put an end to the mercenary
Reckless time travel Shenanigans however
we don't know any more details about
this yet Deadpool 3 is scheduled for
release on November 8 2024.
fans of the alien franchise can look
forward to plenty of new releases in the
future in addition to the first series
of the franchise which is currently
being produced under the direction of
Fargo Creator Noah Holly and is to be
set on a futuristic Earth the movie
Alien Romulus is also in production this
will be a reboot of the 1979 classic to
be directed by Evil Dead director Fede
Alvarez meanwhile more detailed
information regarding the production
schedule has become known because as an
entry on the website of the film and
television industry Alliance suggests
filming will start as early as February
6 2023 in Budapest Hungary although
there are no precise details about the
plot of the reboot at least the fact
that filming is scheduled to start soon
indicates that the script has been
finalized and that the cast is complete
the only information that has been made
public so far is the signing of
potential leading actress Kaylee spaney
who was last seen in the HBO series
mayor of East Town Ridley Scott is once
again occupying an important position in
the completely Standalone film as he
serves as the executive producer of
alien Romulus whether Romulus is
actually the final title or whether it
is simply the working title has not been
fully clarified the planned release date
on the Hulu streaming service is also
not known yet but a 2024 release is
deemed realistic
Jerry Bruckheimer is without a doubt one
of the most experienced and successful
film producers in Hollywood his career
includes films such as Black Hawk Down
Top Gun Bad Boys National Treasure
Pirates of the Caribbean and many series
most notably several CSI Series in an
exclusive Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter he now gave some insights into
various Productions including sequels
and spin-offs to some of his best known
films after Margot Robbie announced in
November that she would not be playing a
part in the upcoming Pirates of the
Caribbean spin-off after all things
initially went quiet for the movie
series according to Bruckheimer the
spin-off with Robbie has not been put on
hold instead a second spin-off is
currently being prioritized this one is
being developed by Chernobyl director
Craig Mason and Pirates of the Caribbean
writer Ted Elliott and will focus on a
younger cast the film with Robbie by
contrast requires a little more time but
neither the film nor the leading actress
had been written off Bruckheimer
emphasized rockheimer also also had
something to add about a third Top Gun
film he said that production had not
really made much progress mainly due to
lead actor Tom Cruise and his
time-consuming involvement in Mission
Impossible 8 as well as a still Untitled
space film therefore the coming months
and possibly even the following year
will be challenging for the production
of Top Gun 3. Bad Boys 4 was also
briefly touched on in the interview and
the prospects look generally positive
Bruckheimer believes that the movie will
be made despite the hubbub's surrounding
actor Will Smith and sincerely hopes
that audiences will forgive the 54 year
old for his freakout all in all
Bruckheimer had some exciting news to
announce about some of the most
anticipated films of the next few years
which film are you looking forward to
the most feel free to let us know in the
comments
and that's it our last news of 2022.
would like to thank you for a wonderful
year with all of you and wish you a
happy New Year for those who might need
something to watch on the couch on New
Year's Day we suggest you check out our
latest original on The Amazing
Spider-Man 3.
[Music]